[Applaus]
[Musik]
die politische und militärische führung
chinas will langfristig vor allem eines
taiwan zurückerobern den teilwahlen
derweil immer mehr menschen davon die
volle unabhängigkeit zu erreichen und in
den vereinigten staaten hofft man dass
der ein oder andere fehltritte china
davon abhält eine echte supermacht zu
werden wir reden hier über ein
gewaltiges globales spielt ein
geopolitisches spiel bei dem dieser
störung und vernichtung das elend und
der massenmord den putins terror horden
über die ukraine gebracht haben alle
alarmglocken läuten lässt plötzlich
haben viele länder auf der ganzen welt
eine sache erkannt selbst in der mitte
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts kann
der krieg für uns alle viel schneller
zur alltäglichen realität werden als wir
es uns vorgestellt haben nun ja manche
länder haben diese realität klarer
erkannt als andere aber dies ändert
nichts daran dass sie bereits
eingetreten ist kein anderes erreichen
industrieland steht dieser realität
jedoch näher als taiwan
[Musik]
die geopolitische militärische und
strategische situation dieser insel
weist viele ähnlichkeiten mit der
ukraine auf sowohl russland als auch
china erheben ansprüche mit dem sie auf
die eine oder andere weise die
souveränität ihrer opfer vernichten oder
stark verletzen wollen außerdem sind
sowohl taiwan als auf die ukraine länder
die mit unterschiedlichem erfolg
versucht haben ihre eigenen
institutionen aufzubauen beziehungen zum
westen zu knüpfen und ein demokratisches
system zu konsolidieren
aber eins nach dem anderen lasst uns die
entwicklung kurz rekapitulieren und
etwas ordnung in das imperialistische
chaos bringen in das putin und ski die
welt gestürzt haben den taiwanesen gegen
ein licht auf als das regime von
shipping die de facto unabhängig hat er
ehemals freien stadt hongkong mit einem
federstrich beendete das war der erste
warnschuss den man in taipeh vernommen
hat jetzt hat die russischen invasion in
der ukraine die alarmglocken erneut
läuten lassen es handelt sich um die
zweite und vielleicht letzte warnung
[Musik]
der im jahrzehntelang galt es als
selbstverständlich dass die chinesische
sogenannte volksbefreiungsarmee nicht in
der lage war in taiwan einzumarschieren
und die kontrolle über die insel zu
übernehmen viele militärexperten zufolge
könnte sich das jedoch sehr bald ändern
angesichts leerer die china derzeit hat
könnte der asiatischen riesen in den
jahren 2025 bis 27 bereits seine
offensive zu starten und genauso wie
amerikanische geheimdienst unmittelbar
vor putins angriff mit ihren warnungen
richtig lagen könnten sie auch in diesem
fall recht verhalten zu tragisch und zu
real uns dies auch jetzt wieder
vorkommen war er in taiwan ist man
deswegen jedoch hellwach und beobachtet
sehr genau was änderten kräne passiert
die entschlossenheit und das
durchhaltevermögen die das ukrainische
volk nach der russischen invasion
gezeigt hat haben taiwan inspiriert und
uns darin bestärkt unsere freiheit zu
verteidigen und vergesst nicht dass es
sich hierbei nicht nur um leere worte
handelt die brutale russische invasion
hat die taiwanesische regierung bereits
dazu veranlasst konkrete maßnahmen zu
ergreifen taiwan prüft verlängerung der
wehrpflicht über die ihr monate hinaus
der minister teil der parlament mit dass
vorschläge geprüft werden und noch in
diesem jahr ein plan vorgelegt werden
soll pekings druck auf dem russlands
krieg in der ukraine haben eine debatte
darüber ausgelöst wie die verteidigung
gestärkt werden kann aber jenseits der
großen schlagzeilen welche lehren kann
teil waren aus der ukraine ziel was kann
das land von zeilen rennen vom land von
golo die mosel ins die lernen und was
nicht aufgepasst
lehren aus der ukraine
bis jetzt hat der krieg in der ukraine
dazu gedient zwei ideen hervorzuheben
erstens hat sich gezeigt dass eine
zahlen richtig stärkere position nicht
immer einen militärischen sieg
garantiert 2 selbst wenn es sich bei den
angreifenden land um eine atommacht und
einen wichtigen lieferanten wichtiger
güter handelt ist die westliche allianz
möglicherweise bereit einen verbündeten
der um die bewahrung seines direktorin
und so seine unabhängigkeit kämpft die
notwendige unterstützung zukommen zu
lassen und vergesst nicht dass darüber
bis zum angriff der russen auf die
ukraine viele zweifel geherrscht haben
aber es geht noch weiter wenn sich die
westlichen länder schon hinter die
ukraine stellen die im wesentlichen ein
getreideexporteure ist dann stellt euch
mal vor wie solidarisch die sich
gegenüber dem land zeigen dass mehr als
die hälfte aller modernen halbleiter auf
der welt produziert und das sagen nicht
wir sondern auch us präsident joe biden
selbst
beiden sagt die usa würden militärische
eingreifen wenn china in taiwan
einmarschieren würde kommentare während
des tokyo besuchs lassen zweifel
aufkommen ob die usa von ihrer politik
der strategischen zweideutigkeit
abrücken doch abgesehen von einer
hypothetischen reaktion der vereinigten
staaten gibt es einige prägnante formeln
detail waren bereits jetzt aus der
ukrainischen erfahrung ziehen kann
zunächst einmal müssen wir denken dass
taiwan als insel einem hohen risiko
ausgesetzt ist belagert zu werden
tatsächlich ist es sehr wahrscheinlich
dass china vor der eigentlichen
militärischen offensive eine kombination
aus belagerung technik und hybriden
kriegsführung maßnahmen wie cyber
angriffen oder sabotage aller art
einsetzen sagt um der belagerung zu
widerstehen muss teilbaren nach den
erfahrungen von städten wie mario pohl
oder attraktiv als erstes seine
ölreserven verdoppeln damit die armee
ihre operation fähigkeit
aufrechterhalten kann
[Musik]
das taiwanesische erdöl verwaltungs
gesetz liegt derzeit hoch über reserven
in höhe von 30 tagen gemessen am
durchschnittlichen vorjahresverbrauch
vor also etwa eine million barrel pro
tag nach den erfahrungen in der ukraine
raten legt der experten bei waren nun
diese vorräte auf mindestens 60 tage zu
verdoppeln außerdem sollten diese
vorräte in hohen lagen und über das
ganze land verteilt gelagert werden
sowohl zum schutz vor prozessen
angriffen als auch damit das öl dank der
schwerkraft auch bei unterbrechung der
stromversorgung transportiert werden
kann um die stromversorgung
sicherzustellen raten militärexperten
außerdem zum bau mehrerer generatoren
unmittelbare nähe der öl reservoirs
[Musik]
da die häfen zu den bevorzugten zielen
der angreifer werden könnten muss sich
das land darauf vorbereiten seine
logistik über den luft und vor allem den
landweg aufrecht zu erhalten das heißt
ohne die hafeninfrastruktur nutzen zu
müssen insgesamt wird geschätzt dass die
dafür notwendigen infrastrukturmaßnahmen
taiwan mehr als vier milliarden dollar
kosten könnten das klingt nach viel geld
aber macht euch eines klar die
sicherstellung der ölversorgung des
militärs könnte den gesamten verlauf des
krieges bestimmen ebenso empfehlen die
experten dass das land dringend seine
vorräte an grundnahrungsmitteln auf ein
minimum von 120 tagen aufstocken auf der
ganzen insel wasserbrunnen bauen und ein
effektives satelliten internet
infrastruktur einrichten sollte das
internet wird zur lebensader für die
ukraine in der ukraine hat die starlight
technologie einen ort gefunden an die
sie sich in einem ganz anderes szenario
bewähren kann also welche sie eigentlich
gedacht war während seine invasion hat
russland versucht die ukrainische
kommunikationsinfrastruktur immer wieder
sowohl mit militärischen waffen als auch
mit cyber angriffen lahmzulegen die idee
in der dieser ersten reihe von maßnahmen
wäre es teil waren darauf vorzubereiten
so lange durchzuhalten bis
internationale hilfe eintrifft oder
china das handtuch wirft aber natürlich
muss dieses ziel neben der infrastruktur
vor allem eine effektive militärische
verteidigung sicherstellen
[Musik]
und hier kommen wir zur zweiten lektion
die osthessische invasion in der ukraine
lernt es ist möglich die
handlungsfähigkeit selbst einer
überlegenen armee maßgeblich einzudämmen
dazu müssen wir unbedingt über
militärische ausrüstung und vor allem
über drei bestimmte verteidigungs achsen
sprechen ballistische verteidigung
luftverteidigung und see verteidigung
denn der krieg in der ukraine dient
nicht nur als lernerfahrung vorteil
waren sondern auch für china besuchen
der asiatische riese zum beispiel
erkannt haben dass er um eine schnelle
militärische überlegenheit zu erlangen
erst einmal brutal zuschlagen muss bevor
er die invasion in großem stil aus rollt
das ist eine sache die russland vor dem
einmarsch in der ukraine sträflich
vernachlässigt hat um diesen mehr als
wahrscheinliches szenario also gewachsen
zu sein musste waren seine verteidigung
gegen ballistische raketen und
präzisionswaffen verstärken
der zeitplan die taiwanesische
streitkräfte bereits ihre 350 patrick
petri raketensysteme aufzurüsten und 300
zusätzliche abfangjäger zu kaufen nach
den erfahrungen in der ukraine
während diese anstrengungen jedoch
wahrscheinlich noch größer sein müssen
zum beispiel könnte der kauf von drohnen
und deren ausrüstung mit elektronischer
kriegsführung forciert werden was die
treffsicherheit chinesische lenkraketen
verringern würde dies würde dann einen
viel größeren militärischen und
wirtschaftlichen aufwand für den
angreifer erfordern es gibt sogar
stimmen auf der insel die vereinigten
staaten dazu zu drängen ihr teenager die
system auch in taiwan zu stationieren
aber es scheint unwahrscheinlich dass
roche legten dazu bereit wäre als
teenager die in südkorea installiert
wurde kam es zu einem großen
diplomatischen streit mit china was die
armee der ukraine außerdem demonstrieren
konnte war die tatsache dass es möglich
ist den angreifer daran zu hindern die
luftüberlegenheit zu erlangen und dass
dies auch der schlüssel zu verlangsamen
und seine gesamt operationen sein kann
die ukrainische verteidigung zeichne
sich dadurch aus dass in mehreren
schichten organisiert ist die erste
angreift macht schwer oder unmöglich
machen eine luftüberlegenheit zu
erreichen ohne luftüberlegenheit könnte
china so gut wie keinen militärischen
angriffsplan gegenteil waren in die tat
umsetzen so könnte teil waren mit dem p
trades eine erste verteidigungs schicht
mit größerer reichweite und höhe
aufbauen eine mittlere schicht mit
anderen flugabwehr batterien von
geringerer präzision und eine letzte
schicht mit tragbaren flugabwehrraketen
die funktion daten selbst getragen
werden können sogenannten mentees
in der ukraine haben wir alle wie
beispiel der von der nato gespendet ist
den gast sowie das trainers gesehen
welche sich bereits in arenal der
ukrainischen armee befanden und mit
denen zahlreiche hubschrauber drohnen
und sogar gelegentlich russische
kampfflugzeuge abgeschossen worden und
zwar in einem so starken ausmaß dass
sich russische kampfpiloten oft
weigerten missionen in tieferes seines
land zu fliegen von patrouille flügen
ganz zu schweigen die russische
luftwaffe muss sich auf einzeleinsätze
beschränken bei denen sie nur punktuell
in den luftraum der ukraine reihen und
sehr schnell wieder raus fliegt der
zwang zu dieser beschränkten taktik und
die völlige absenz von patrouille flügen
sind somit ein klares symptom dafür dass
die gegebene asymmetrischen struktur der
ukrainisch luftverteidigung gegenüber
den russischen streitkräften die
erlangung einer russischen
luftüberlegenheit erfolgreich und
dauerhaft verhindert und dieses szenario
könnte auch teil waren gut anwenden
[Musik]
aber kommt es zur letzten achse der
maritimen verteidigung da es sich beim
opfer um eine insel handelt ist dieser
punkt natürlich sehr wichtig um eine
invasion zu verhindern muss ist
heilbaren gelingen landungsoperation zu
vereiteln und zu verhindern dass china
die küstenlinien um von dort stellungen
an land anzugreifen
taiwan könnte zum beispiel nicht nur
daraus lernen wie die ukraine eine große
zahl von seeminen verlegt hat sondern
vor allem die kritisch sein könnte anti
schiffs raketen und präzisions gelenkte
munition entlang der gesamten küste des
landes im kleinen depots zu lagern und
mobil zu halten so dass es für den
angreifer schwer zu entdecken sind auf
diese weise hat ist die ukraine
geschafft die moskwa mit ihren selbst
entwickelten neptun raketen zu versenken
indem sie unbemerkt blieben analyse
zeigt kriegsschiff moskwa blind
gegenüber ukrainischen raketenangriff
die besatzungen der rps moskwa war blind
und nicht auf den ukrainischen
raketenangriff vorbereitet der das
russische flaggschiff im schwarzen meer
versenkte
und deshalb von raketen getroffen
ukraine behauptet zweites russisches
schiff versenkt zu haben allerdings
haben die erfahrungen aus dem ukraine
trick gezeigt dass sich taiwans
derzeitige bestände als eindeutig
unzureichend erweisen könnten selbst
angesichts solcher nachrichten taiwan
plant angesichts der spannungen mit
china seine jährliche raketen
produktionskapazität in diesem jahr auf
fast 500 zu verdoppeln taiwan rüstet
seit einiger zeit seine verteidigung auf
zum beispiel mit dem kauf von 400 punkte
abwehrraketen aus den usa und 25
radargeräten um sie zu bedienen diese
raketen könnten in der lage seien
chinesische schiffe kurz nach dem
auslaufen aus dem hafen zu treffen die
quantitative analyse der kampfhandlungen
in der ukraine hat nun eindeutig gezeigt
dass die taiwanesischen planzahlen
unzureichend sind darüber hinaus wird
noch mal eine viel größere zahl benötigt
um in den wirklich wirksame abschreckung
macht aufzubauen denn wenn wir dieses
jahr etwas gelernt haben dann dass im
falle skrupelloser diktatoren und
aggressoren nur eine wirklich gute
abschreckung in der lage ist einen krieg
zu verhindern keine diplomatie keine
verhandlungen kein equipment und auch
kein wandel durch handel diese
potentaten verstehen nur eine sprache
und man muss sie ihnen permanent und mit
überdeutlicher lautstärke ins gesicht
brüllen
und damit gehen wir auch schon zu
dritten schlüssel formel mit der sich
teil waren schützen muss an dieser
stelle müssen wir einen ganz besonderen
punkt hervorheben in denen die ukraine
russland buchstäblich bei nicht
geschlagen hat in krieg der native die
öffentliche kriegs kommunikation darin
hat sie als grosses talent bewiesen und
wenn die ukraine etwas geschafft hat
dann war es die unterstützung der großen
bevölkerungsmehrheit in der westlichen
länder zu gewinnen wie lenz gehört
sofort erkannt dass die ukraine zwar als
opfer der invasion theoretisch die
sympathien der mitleidige
weltöffentlichkeit für sich gewinnen
müssten aber er war auch klar dass es
sich hierbei keineswegs um ein
automatismus handelt denn oft laufen
solche hochgradig gruppendynamischen
prozesse extrem komisch aber mit
ungewissen verlauf und ausgang und in
der tat war es auch in diesem fall kein
kinderspiel denn gerade am anfang
wollten einige regierungen die für sie
unangenehme situation eher wieder in
different aussetzen die königsdisziplin
für geübte mikado spieler wie olaf
scholz die kommunikationsstrategie der
ukraine musste deswegen besonders klar
sein sie hat sich der welt nicht nur als
opfer einer invasion präsentiert sondern
auch und vor allem als ein land das für
demokratie offenheit und europäische
welt kämpft und dieses bild hat die
nicht unterstützung der ukraine so
geschmacklos werden lassen dass sogar
die europäische union die sache in die
nehmen musste außerdem hat sie zu jeder
zeit eindeutig argumentiert dass ein
sieg der ukraine möglich sei wenn sie
die unterstützung des westens habe mit
anderen worten er hat klar die
verantwortung auf zeit damit sich
niemand unauffällig aus der affäre
ziehen kann und wenn wir nur nach taiwan
blicken befindet es sich für den
kommunikations krieg sogar noch in einer
besseren situation als die arme und
korruptionsgeplagte ukraine in ganz
asien ist es die nummer eins was
bürgerrechte angeht es ist ein
unverzichtbarer technologieführer und
ein wichtiger westlicher verbündeter
seine außenpolitische agenda zu stärken
und vor allem zu so etwas wie dem mekka
der freiheit und der bürgerrechte in der
region zu werden könnte der schlüssel
sein um notfalls auf die massive und
eindeutige unterstützung des westens
ziel zu können dieses thema haben wir
auf diesen politikbereichen früheren
videos über die verteidigung taiwans
behandelt die ich euch in der
beschreibung verlinken werde
[Musik]
schließlich der vierte schlüsselfaktor
die allgemeine mobilisierung es handelt
sich um einen punkt den wir bereits vor
kriegsausbruch in mehreren unseren
videos über die verteidigung der ukraine
hervorgehoben haben die rede ist vor
allem von den sogenannten territorialen
verteidigungskräfte die ab 2015
geschaffen würden und eine
schlüsselrolle bei der verteidigung der
ukraine spielen es handelt sich um eine
gut organisierte unterstützungs armee
die sogar als teil der streitkräfte
etabliert wurde sie besteht aus
reservisten und drei belegen die eine
ausbildung erhalten und für aufgaben wie
kontrolle der sicherheit des
direktoriums die logistische
unterstützung der truppen die aufklärung
die durchführung von hinterhalten und
sabotageaktionen und sogar die agile
unterstützung der kampfhandlungen der
berufsarmee bei bedarf mit eigenen
verbänden sicherstellen können der
springende punkt ist nämlich dass für
jeden aktiv kämpfenden soldaten an der
front eine große zahl von unterstützungs
personal notwendig ist damit dieser sein
einsatz effektiven optimal durchführen
kann das fängt bei der aufklärung
planung über den aufbau die erhaltung
und durchführung der logistik bis hin
zur dokumentation auswertung der einsatz
ergebnisse fahrzeuge und waffensysteme
müssen repariert instand gehalten und
gewartet werden und die truppe muss
ständig mit frische munition und
proviant versorgt werden die idee
dahinter ist die verteidigung qualitativ
so hochwertig wie möglich zu gestalten
sie so wasserdicht wie möglich zu machen
und ist damit den angreifer unmöglich zu
machen seine ziele unter für ihn
erträglichen kosten zu erreichen dies
ist das einmaleins des zermürbungskrieg
cez gewinnt quantität mal qualität das
nun kriegserprobter ukrainische modell
wurde bereits von polen kopiert und nun
gibt es stimmen die meinen dass taiwan
dasselbe tun könnte das allerdings
könnte sehr kompliziert werden dann an
diesen punkt kommen wir zu dem was teil
waren vielleicht nicht von der ukraine
lernen kann also aufgepasst
[Musik]
was teil waren vielleicht nicht lernen
kann
territoriale verteidigungskräfte haben
eine schlüsselrolle in widerstand der
ukraine gespielt und das macht sinn wie
bereits gesagt habe kann die verdichtung
der verteidigung in einem gebiet eine
invasion egal ob blitz oder
zermürbungskrieg für den angreifer in
einen riesigen albtraum verwandelt
gleichzeitig setzte die berufsarmee
dabei ressourcen frei um sich auf den
angriff auf den feinden zu konzentrieren
dank dieser kräfte waren ukrainische
städte wie gfk tv besser oder mikulov so
stark forciert das russische soldaten
nicht in sie eindringen konnten und weil
es ja blitzschnell aufgerieben und
eliminiert worden doch trotz ihrer
enormen rolle kann diese taktik
eventuell nicht durch teil waren
nachgeahmt werden
denn in taiwan gibt es zwar ein
zivilschutz chor aber in wahrheit ist
ist nicht militarisiert und vollständig
der polizei unterstellt es handelt sich
um ein chor das vor allem bei
evakuierungen oder naturkatastrophen wie
erdbeben oder überschwemmungen helfen
soll seine mitglieder erhalten keine
ausbildung an waffen und es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass sich diese
fertigkeit in eigenregie angeeignet
haben während in der ukraine nämlich
nach der russischen invasion 2014
paramilitärische wer sportvereine wie
pilze nach einem warmen sommerregen aus
dem boden geschossen sind haben wir es
in taiwan mit einem land zu tun dass
sich mit dem strengsten waffengesetze
der welt schmückt
[Musik]
diese sind derart streng dass man sogar
für den kauf eines luftgewehrs oder
einer fischer hat ohne eine polizeiliche
genehmigung benötigt tatsächlich ist
taiwan weltweit das land mit der
niedrigsten zahl an privat gehaltenen
schusswaffen pro kopf überhaupt
insgesamt besitzen die rund 24 millionen
teil lesen nur rund 10.000 legale waffen
das sind gerade mal vier wochen pro
10.000 einwohner
zum vergleich die 83 millionen deutschen
besitzen 15,8 millionen private waffen
also mit 1900 pro 10.000 einwohnern rund
475 x merkbaren als die taiwaner bei den
43 millionen ukraine sind es 44
millionen legale waffen also circa 1.000
pro 10.000 einwohner aber in der ukraine
dürften solche offiziellen zahlen
sowieso nicht besonders repräsentativ
für den privaten rüstungs grad der
bevölkerung seien die zahlen zeigen
jedoch eindeutig trotz der permanenten
kriegsgefahr urs roth china verfügt
kurioserweise wohl kein anderes volk
über weniger schuss praxis als die
taiwaner denn obwohl es ein
militärdienst gibt ist dieser mit nur
vier monaten sehr kurz bemessen und
bietet derzeit keine effektive
ausbildung für eine kriegssituation
außerdem werde versucht diese zivilen
streitkräfte in einer art zu handeln
schlichtweg illegal und ok ich weiß was
ihr denkt gesetze kann man ändern und
jetzt wäre doch eine gute gelegenheit
dazu nun ein die wahrheit ist dass es
selbst jetzt in dieser situation nicht
ausreichend politischen willen zu geben
scheint und diese wichtigen reformen
anzugehen zumindest ist das der heutige
stand der dinge wir bleiben auf jeden
fall am ball denn zum thema teil dann
gibt es noch eine menge zu sagen
vielleicht wird man diese insel das
schicksal der freien welt noch mehr
hängen als zurzeit an der ukraine
vergesst also bitte nicht das abo um
keines unserer zukünftigen videos zu
verpassen falls ihr schon ein abo aber
noch nicht die glocke aktiviert habt
holt das jetzt bitte schnell nach ich
danke euch und jetzt seid ihr erstmal
mit eurer eigenen meinung an der reihe
sollte teil waren die reform in seiner
erwartung und der dienst gesetze angehen
und auch bewaffnete zivile der
heftigkeit setzen könnte die
inselrepublik auch auf diese weise stark
und umfassende widerstands und partisan
den strukturen aufbauen sowie ist die
ukraine zwischen 2010 und 22 geschafft
haben glaubt ihr dass taiwan einer
chinesischen invasion mindestens so
erfolgreich widerstehen könnte wie die
ukraine wie immer sind auf eure
diskussionsbeiträge schon sehr gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video gleich
noch etwas arbeit gelernt habe falls sie
alles gelernt und tasten freunden
natürlich wollen wir uns ausgedacht hat
über eine spende von euch ist dieses
projekt weiterzuführen dem paper link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]